the last of us captured plenty of parts
when it launched in 2013 but even if
you're playing it for the first time in
2020 like I am Jolla Nellie's
cross-country journey is just as moving
and impactful here's why while there are
always elements of games that are bound
to date after a long enough period of
time The Last of Us is greatest strength
is timeless that is its betrayal of
complex characters embroiled in an
emotional and heart-wrenching fight for
survival it's the things that don't age
the game's performances pacing and
excellent use of the linear narrative
format that keep the magic of Naughty
Dog's post-apocalyptic epic intact seven
years later I played an hour or two of
The Last of Us when it first came out
but somewhere in the brick littered
arenas and conveniently placed chest
high walls it lost me that isn't to say
the beginning didn't absolutely break my
heart though it remains one of the best
interest to a game I've ever seen
but it took me until this year to give
the game a second chance and really get
into it The Last of Us isn't framed
around boss encounters or becoming an
unstoppable powerhouse the experience
thrives on instilling a strong sense of
vulnerability you spend the entire game
scrambling pushing through one tense and
uncertain situation into the next and
the feeling that that brings you as a
player is very similar to the state Joel
and Ellie find themselves in throughout
the game the mechanics of the Last of Us
elevate its themes of survival and
desperation keeping resources sparse
inventory limits low and crafting items
essential enforces the idea that you're
fighting tooth and nail to survive
against portal odds this sort of shared
experience between the player and
characters creates empathy that enhances
the impact of the emotional story The
Last of Us presses its troubled
characters into horrible situations
forces them to persevere through tragedy
and ultimately that changes who they are
and the relationships they form the
game's biggest success is in how it
India's you to its characters brutal as
they can be encouraging you to care for
them and want to know where their story
leads the Last of Us leverages a linear
narrative and a very deliberate pace to
drive its most impactful scenes and
character moments the game school
underpins and elevates each moment as it
runs the gamut from severe
attention to heart-pounding gunfights -
heartfelt dialogues using the linear
narrative format not only lets Naughty
Dog tell the story it wants to but have
you experienced it in the precise way
the developer wants you to in my opinion
there's no better way to tell an
affecting videogames story especially if
it's a story worth telling there are so
many touches that make the last of us
feel especially alive and impactful
collectable notes left behind encourage
you to delve deeper into the game world
and inform what's happened to the people
you encounter and how the world has been
reshaped by the outbreak Ellie's
tendency to independently knows her way
around the game world makes it feel like
you're with an ally and not escorting an
NPC most obviously the game's
performances remain as excellent today
as they were seven years ago and elevate
the characters above and beyond the
writing The Last of Us isn't a game to
be won there's room for multiple
approaches in combat and whether you're
a gun-toting hero who shoots their way
through every arena or more like me
taking five times as long to crawl
stealthily through there's no right or
wrong way to go about it the game isn't
interested in rewarding or punishing you
for your preferred approach to combat it
just wants you to keep moving ahead
whether you finish a fight stocked up on
health or managed by the skin of your
teeth just like Joel and Ellie survival
is what matters not how you survive The
Last of Us makes your actions a
narrative device making you part of the
story in its final moments it comes full
circle in making you feel what it's
characters feel going beyond just a
well-made zombie apocalypse story the
further you get through the game world
the more you understand the depth of its
brutality and how it has changed the
characters trying to survive within it
but it also shines a light on how and
why characters hold tight to the things
that matter to them and as a result it's
shocking final moments feel earned truly
brilliant stories are timeless
especially those presented in compelling
ways it's why the Last of Us became so
iconic and why there's such excitement
for the sequel
is the case for Joel and Ellie it
doesn't matter how you make it to the
end it just matters that you do and
theirs is a story that deserves to be
seen through
you